[Musica]
a
[Applauso]
io faccio l'educatore e il mondo di
educatori è un po particolare
a volte ci piace stare lì a guardarci a
dirci che abbiamo fatto un intervento
come doveva essere fatto che magari una
parola che abbiamo detto abbiamo anche
la presunzione che sia stata una
illuminazione per qualcuno che riusciamo
a cambiare la vita di qualcuno anche con
una semplice parola con un gesto con il
modo in cui mi pongo mi è capitata una
cosa un giorno che ero seduto a tavola e
mio figlio
zeno aveva 4 anni dice io la minestra
non la mangio la minestra andare di
mangiare no io la minestra non la mangio
non la voglio genova la minestra ti fa
bene c'è anche la verdura è appunto io
non la voglio sì ma non si sente c'è ma
non si sente mangia latifah bene
zeno devi mangiare altrimenti non va
bene devi crescere
io non la voglio va bene
all
va bene zeno prende il cucchiaio e
arrabbiato inizia a mangiare la minestra
già perché stai mangiando la minestra
perché tu mi hai detto di mangiarla sì
molto ha detto che non la voleva aveva
capito tutto
io l'ho capito dopo aveva capito tutto
perché io avevo detto va bene ma non
arrivava
va bene arrivava qualcos'altro
ci sono diversi approcci non ci si muove
verso un problema verso una situazione
verso un'altra persona tutti alla stessa
maniera
mi sembra chiaro ma se è così chiaro
perché non lo facciamo
racconta la ricercatrice maria l
immordino yang che una volta una bambina
della classe seconda della scuola
primaria di fronte a un problema
apparentemente semplice una bambina
anche di quelle lei dice che solitamente
dava soddisfazione alle insegnanti
il problema diceva puoi si può
parcheggiare una macchina larga due
metri in un garage largo due metri e
mezzo
la bambina dopo aver pensato per molto
tempo a tutto questo ha risposto no
perché se io parcheggio se quella
persona anzi parcheggia la macchina
larga due metri in un garage largo due
mesi e mezzo non può aprire la portiera
la risposta è giusta o sbagliata
dipende la bambina non era legata
solamente al problema matematico due
metri e mezzo due metri si no ha
probabilmente smontato il problema è la
ri costruito tenendo di conto delle sue
conoscenze diremmo della sua cultura ma
la usiamo troppo questa parola bisogna
smettere delle sue conoscenze delle sue
esperienze di quello che aveva visto
delle dei film dei cartoni delle cose
che aveva sentito dei problemi che
magari aveva incontrato la sua famiglia
a qualcun altro
e la risposta era no è infatti
giustamente l'insegnante prese quella
risposta come buona poi c'è tutto il
capitolo delle emozioni e questo
complica moltissimo le cose perché oltre
alle mie
io sono influenzato dalle emozioni di
chi mi sta intorno
dai percorsi mentali di chi mi sta
intorno io vengo influenzato le emozioni
incidono tantissimo sulle prestazioni le
emozioni incidono ancora di più sulle
relazioni sono l'elemento che molto
spesso le determina
tornando al discorso quando mi vuoi dire
che una cosa va bene
dimmi che va bene io spesso per vedermi
come genitore nel mio lavoro educativo
guardo i miei figli
guardo 0 e guardo d'ora e cerco di
capire in che modo loro avviano le loro
relazioni
perché il modo in cui loro avviano le
loro relazioni con le altre persone
siamo io e la loro mamma è chiarissimo è
come se fosse disegnato il davanti
quando io guardo come si muovono nelle
relazioni miei figli
io difficilmente sento le parole che ho
detto
le belle frasi le cose effetto ma ci
vedo il modo in cui l'ho detto la parte
di emozione che ho usato per caricare
quelle frasi quella passa e non
solamente quando sono rivolte a loro
quando sono rivolte un po a tutti
ma a un certo punto facendo teatro da
anni a un certo punto sma incontro il
clown incontro il mondo del clown lo
incontro a varie distanze con le
distanze più lunghe alcuni incontri sono
più ravvicinati incontro slava polunin
un grandissimo incontro paolo nani
incontro molto più vicino andrè casaca e
gli altri clown del teatro carte e ho
l'occasione di vedere il clown che
lavorano con i bambini ed è un qualcosa
di meraviglioso
allora piano piano ho iniziato a
camminare da clown nel mondo
dell'educazione non faccio il clown non
lo faccio
non faccio spettacoli ho iniziato a
camminare come un clown nel mondo degli
educatori
ho visto delle cose meravigliose
ho visto dei risultati meravigliosi ho
visto dei bambini che mettevano sopra un
palcoscenico di due metri per uno un
conflitto che magari c'era stato qualche
giorno prima e che non aveva avuto non
dico una soluzione positiva ma un
progresso era rimasto lì l'ho visto
mettere in scena e trovare delle
possibilità che qualche giorno prima non
erano neanche immaginabili o immaginate
probabilmente erano immaginabili ma non
immaginate ho visto bambini e bambine
che per vari motivi non avevano mai
parlato come sto facendo io in classe ma
li ho visti giganteggiare dietro un naso
rosso e li ho visti comunicare delle
cose che io mi sarei sognato e li hanno
visti i loro compagni le loro compagne
le loro insegnanti e da quel momento si
è innescato un meccanismo che ha fatto
sì che dopo un po arrivassero anche le
parole ho visto dei risultati
meravigliosi soprattutto quando ho
capito che quelli non erano risultati
erano inizi perché da lì partiva
qualcos'altro da questo solitamente
scaturisce una risata e va benissimo è
la risata è fondamentale non vi sto
parlare di tutto quello che c'è intorno
allo studio sul ridere ma è una cosa
incredibile nel clown si lavora
tantissimo con il corpo il corpo che
noia lo usiamo sempre per fare le stesse
cose sempre quando si lavora sul clown a
volte al corpo chiediamo di guidarci gli
diciamo gli chiediamo che sia lui a
portarci da qualche parte vediamo fin
dove può arrivare
vediamo cosa succede quando siamo in un
posto dove non poteva arrivare così ci
costerà cosa stava scatta
le coq grandissimo pedagogo teatrale
diceva a volte il corpo sa delle cose
che il cervello ancora non sa è
meraviglioso ho iniziato a fare questo
lavoro ho chiamato la pedagogia clown
non ho inventato niente nulla è che ho
fatto una cosa e per me è stata stupenda
e ho pensato che fosse bella da
raccontare perché magari è una cosa che
riguarda poche persone e riguarda quei
due bambini li quei 5 ma per loro
probabilmente è una cosa grandissima ea
me interessa mi va bene quello che gli
serve quello nella pedagogia clown
il lavoro è quello di costruire insieme
qualcosa
il lavoro è quello di sfuggire da tutti
i meccanismi del dei pregiudizi quando
si fa il clown si fa il clown clown
costruiscono insieme quello che uno
propone l'altro lo accoglie e così via
si fa questo lavoro tutti insieme
dopodiché c'è il momento in cui ognuno
col suo bel naso si mette sul palco da
solo e lì si fa un lavoro di mediazione
tra l'ascoltare el essere ascoltati
voi siete il pubblico fate il pubblico è
più difficile che fare l'attore
lo facciamo dobbiamo imparare io sono
qui sono solo ma io sono la persona che
in questo momento raccoglie l'attenzione
degli altri che mi stanno guardando poi
cambiamo ma ci dobbiamo educare a questa
mediazione
la mediazione è fondamentale tutto
questo alla fine è un movimento verso la
pluralità delle possibilità cercare di
costruire il maggior numero di
possibilità
heinz brewster diceva questo è il mio
imperativo etico
creare situazioni in cui il numero delle
possibilità si accresce deve crescere
perché quando si costruisce insieme
qualcosa ci prendiamo una responsabilità
e si fugge da quella logica ammalata
dell'obe dire e peggio ancora si fugge
da quella logica malata del voler
comandare né obbedire né comandare il
clown lavora sulle cose che non si
vedono
ci sono le cicatrici pescatrice si
vedono che servono perché raccontano chi
sono raccontano cosa ho fatto
lewis madeira scriveva amo l'ambivalenza
poetica di una cicatrice perché dice qui
sono stata ferita e qui sono guarita e
importante ma il clown lavora su altro
quello che non si vede quello che non si
vede abramov al era inglese che fu
chiamato durante la seconda guerra
mondiale dal governo britannico perché
perché troppi aerei britannici venivano
abbattuti dalla contraerea dagli altri
aeree allora fu chiamato per capire dove
andavano rinforzati gli aeroplani ma gli
aeroplani non si possono rinforzare
molto perché poi devono essere agili
devono volare
allora ball cominciò con i suoi
collaboratori a esaminare tutti gli
aerei che rientravano i fori dei
proiettili costruire una mappa con la
forma dell'aeroplano inizio a segnare di
nero
i punti dove gli aerei che rientravano
venivano colpiti alla fine aveva una
mappa dove si vedeva dove tutti gli
aerei erano stati colpiti vald disse
rinforzate le parti bianche come
rinforzate le parti bianche di viso
aperto perché gli aerei che sono
rientrati sono stati colpiti ma
probabilmente sono stati colpiti in
alcuni punti che non sono necessari per
volare gli aerei che non sono rientrati
molto probabilmente
sono stati colpiti nelle parti bianche
quelle che noi non vediamo sono quelli i
punti da rinforzare sul clown si fa la
stessa cosa
l'approccio pedagogico clown segue il
ragionamento di abraham vald si lavora
su quello che non si vede
e per fare questo ti offro una
protezione un piccolo naso rosso perché
con un naso rosso
tu puoi decidere chi sei in quel momento
puoi sperimentare poi cambiare idea
puoi essere diverso da quello che eri
prima poi essere diverso da quello che
vorrei essere dopo potrei rifare quello
che hai già fatto il naso rosso ti mette
ti apre e ti mette a disposizione di
tutti ma è la più piccola ma la più
potente difesa che possiamo avere contro
qualsiasi attacco grazie
[Applauso]